what's up buddy hey how's it going good
man what do you got for me tonight well
i just have a couple i have a couple
questions so i'm a little nervous
because i've been watching it forever
so
um
oh where do i begin well let's say i did
read your book
about the um
you know like the
uh red flags and everything and i just
recently was in a uh
a short relationship and without your
book
it would have really gone downhill like
very bad all right we'll tell the story
so what happened uh basically
well it's one of those things that was
like um
like her money issues she was having a
lot of problems like with her money and
stuff like that
and i thought you know
i'll help her out and then after i
helped her out
i know
um and i made it really listen i laughed
but we've all been there there's guys in
the chat that are laughing and they're
usually laughing because they've all
been there too but carry on
but uh but i decided you know hey i'll
help her out see what's to see how
things are going and whatnot and i made
it really easy for her
to pay pay me back and everything okay
and then we started to like you know
because she just recently just came off
from a divorce
she had two kids but they were like 18
they're 18 or 17 so they were out but
how old are you chad i'm uh 35. and how
old was she
she was 40.
40 year old single mommy of two
yeah but but you know yeah so um
but
broke as well oh my god okay yeah keep
going yeah and um and she and the thing
was like i can always got this hint like
she was always looked down on me because
i kind of like
because i came with a family who like
owned a movie theater and i was really
into movies and so she always kind of
like stumbed her nose to that kind of
stuff
but you know it's i thought okay
whatever and she's such a catch being 40
in debt with two kids in tow yeah yeah
so anyways i just so i was like okay you
know she's you know talking about her ex
how was she he was bad and everything
like that and she's trying to get on her
feet and of course she she wanted to
have like this um
like this uh pet cat to help her and
everything and she's like she needed
like an extra
180 bucks 200 so she can have like the
cat and some food and whatnot i was like
okay i'll help you out you know it's no
biggie
you know and i told her it's like you
can either get it for me or you can get
it from your ex because she said she was
going to get it from her ex
that kind of was like like red flag like
uh why are you still talking to them if
you guys are divorced kind of thing well
they have kids together they're gonna
deal with parenting issues you always
have to remember that yeah that's true
but it was just kind of like still like
to me it was just like
you know if you were gonna go to him for
money while you talk to me about money
kind of thing
so i was like okay i'll give you the
money
and i was like we talked against like i
made it easy for her i was like if you
if you want just pay me 20 bucks here or
there
and you'll be fine as long as you are
wanting to pay me back we're good okay
and so we started chit-chatting and we
started saying like why don't we start
dating because i kind of liked her
before i had to why not one itis with
her okay so you brought up dating first
well
and this is after you're paying off her
death yeah yeah and so i was like you
know you know you're
you know we know why your camera's off
now chad
[Laughter]
yeah well i i just don't have a camera
but but um
so she's like okay all right you know
and we were kind of chit-chatting and
and she kind of
seemed like she had a thing for me but
she kind of like
it's kind of like the way she was like
presenting herself she was kind of like
you know
she just had this like way of like how i
was like i wouldn't say friend zone but
she kind of like put me as this spot you
know yeah she put you in that spot
because because that's where she saw let
me ask you a question the chapter in my
book where i cover
single mommies did you find that that
was accurate with your experience dating
her
um
i has been a while i mean i just uh
watched read the red flags once i didn't
get to the mommy part okay
you'll probably call in next week when
you get through that part
i think like um
i just remember the finance part one
there was there was always a problem
there's always something there's always
like uh you know something and that was
really was the key to make me go okay
this isn't
this isn't the woman i liked a long time
ago this isn't a woman that i like now
so that's why you got rid of her was
because of the money problems no no so
this this is what happened
so um
so i was like okay just pay me 20 bucks
here 20 bucks there you sign a paper
saying that you paid me and we're all
good
and she's like okay okay okay and we
started just doing this dayton and
she came over she gave me some money she
gave me actually like 40 bucks she's
like here's a little bit and we started
talking we started getting to kind of
touchy feeling we actually started to
guess
you were lending a girl that you weren't
banging money
uh
yeah yeah
yeah i just want to clarify that so
you're dating a woman that's older than
you
with two kids divorced with debt
and you're not banging or paying off for
debt
well i was trying to that one day but
okay here's what so we were getting kind
of intimate we were getting a little bit
into it
well and this is where things get like
really
turned for me going like okay this woman
is not not here for me she just wanted
my money is when i was trying to get
more
you know on the kissing part i was like
trying to get her to really be intimate
with me and i just feel her mouth just
clinched
and she's just like not
like she was not letting me go the extra
mile let's basically put it that way
yeah so
her kitty would be drier than the sahara
desert is basically what's going on
there right so you ended up like getting
rid of her after that because the
genuine desire didn't exist yeah like
the minute i realized that desire was
just gone i was like okay you do not
want to negotiate attraction with women
ever it doesn't work out like
her hands have to be all over you
especially in the early stages if
they're not i'm telling you you're
wasting your time and never ever do any
of those other things that i mentioned
before date a single mom
you don't have kids no no no i don't
have never been married
nope never been married how tall are you
uh 510 how much you weigh
uh about 205. what do you do for a
living
i work at a uh at a uh
uh it's a farm and ranch store
okay
it's kind of like um i don't know if you
have them up there in canada but they're
kind of like um
a tractor supply okay but it's a it's a
it's a different brand around this
around where i live i live in like
oklahoma okay so you're dealing with
like uh like equipment stuff
yeah yeah yeah and uh and and like was
she hot at least or were she oh yeah oh
yeah oh gosh yes okay but um yeah don't
do that again don't
like do not get involved with women do
not pay off their debt i mean i would
understand look if you know if she's a
mother your kids and you gotta take care
of her she's home raising the kids or i
don't know she can't work or something
or they lay her off yeah that's when you
take you know that's that's when you're
taking care of things right but this is
a chick that you don't know you just met
her you're not even banging you know
she's she's got money problems already
it's like no like you don't even
continue the conversation next time well
which was funny is that i remember you
said something like that and which also
was another thing we actually
again another problem with my baitedness
that have been happening to me i
actually talked to her about it and then
she said like something like well i'm
just not ready
um i don't want to feel like it right
now because things are going on [ __ ]
anytime a woman has genuine does like
dude women will drive
two hours
at three o'clock in the morning on a
wednesday when she has to work at seven
a.m the next morning to come bang you uh
on her period or throw down to like a
dark towel like well women will do
anything if they have genuine desire for
you just to keep you on the good books
just to keep you happy to keep a smile
on your face you know so you know that
she likes you but this like conversation
of well you know i don't really know you
and i don't feel comfortable right now
get the [ __ ] out of here it's
don't even waste your time it's next
well see that's what's the funny thing
because the minute she said that i was
like i remember you talked about how you
had a date like you were like
immediately after your divorce you had a
date with this lady and she pretty much
had sex off the table and you talked
about how you would you know basically
you would bang her immediately or
something i can't remember what the
story was well let me clarify the story
because people are listening and going
whoa hold on a second so there's a part
in the book where i talk about the
amazonian she was taller and heavier
than what i thought she was gonna be
maybe like 15 pounds heavier not not fat
but more like
curvy uh you know beyond the kind of
curvy that i like so you know she shows
up i'm like all right you know she was
you know she was a good laugh i'm here
already let's go inside and get the damn
beer go and sit down she's a good
conversation right
anyway she starts to tell the story
about how she likes to wait eight dates
before she has sex yes yes that's the
strength and i'm like
i just started laughing i basically spit
out my beer when she said that and i'm
like i don't negotiate desiring when sex
happens right it's got to be a natural
progressive it's not there that's cool
you know i'll move on like i'm a busy
guy i got [ __ ] to do
and then she pauses and she looks at me
and she kind of looks at her drink and
then she kind of like gestures towards
the bathroom she goes okay then let's go
to the bathroom it's [ __ ] right now
okay so when a woman has genuine desire
and you pass your [ __ ] [ __ ] test
which when you get good at it you well
um you won't have a problem with this
that by the way was like one of the few
times in my life that i turned down sex
from a woman that like advanced on me it
doesn't normally happen but i just
didn't find her like that hot i don't
like like six foot ten
not six foot ten she was about six foot
tall um you know in height like she was
way too tall for me well but yeah so
that was that story i remembered so when
she started saying like i'm not ready
and everything i remember that story and
i go hold on hold on and then i started
explaining her it's like look i'm a guy
i'm gonna need sex soon so if you're
gonna tell me all this stuff
then what's the point right she's like
well you know maybe if we could do this
and blah blah blah and then like
do what exactly like you know get
intimate like she said something for her
cats yeah i know right
but like um she's like well i can get
intimate like when you come back from
lunch on your lunch break when i'm at
home and everything like that it's just
like well okay but why is the problem
now okay so so chad here's here's what i
want you to do um i got to start taking
some of the other calls here but here's
what i want you to do so here's your
homework i want you to lean into genuine
desire a little bit more so um just play
with it just test it out you know let's
say you're being playful with a chick
and she's coming over instruct her to do
things that you like
just say i want you to walk in the door
it's unlocked i don't want you to say a
word i want you to do this that and the
other thing
and make make up whatever you want it
can be out be as outrageous as you want
you know whatever sexual things that you
want and if she does it you've got
genuine burning desire in your hands if
she protests
she's going to start negotiating if
she's still talking she's kind of
indifferent sort of thing so like kind
of lean into figuring out what that
looks like because once you see it once
you experience it it's it's it it vastly
improves your
experiences dealing with women you're
going to have a lot more fun right like
you're never going to go like black pill
and think oh this sucks it's not you
know worth my time when you experience
genuine burning desire from a woman you
know what it looks like yeah well um
also to finish off my story she did pay
me back all the money though i finally
was able to get her all my money back
from her but anyways how much how much
did you end up letting her like 200
bucks it's not much yeah
but yeah but anyways thanks for the talk
thanks buddy take care hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you